if you had trouble with the this is the
tricky expansions question and we did
treat expressions a while ago and we
didn't spend that much time enough
because kind of like an isolated silent
mission which is a little bit different
to you know when we're doing you know
we're doing calculus try it they're all
intertwined so you spend a lot of time
practicing then this one not so much
okay so how does it work that's what you
get given okay I've written it as the
main thing because that's what I'm gonna
work off in a second this is what they
ask you what's the value of that and the
keys that must be exact
okay so before we dive into working on
these you have to remember what the
expansion is okay so what is the
extension of sine alpha headsman sine
alpha cos beta okay and then sine
retains the side right so - get in - -
[Music]
as in psy and he retains the sine as
opposed to close so here's the point I
want an exact value sign up because beta
cos alpha sine beta there the pieces I
need four pieces and I only have two of
them so I have to use these pieces to
work out what the other two pieces look
like okay so I'm taking another domain
we're gonna talk about that in a second
but basically you want to think about
this as representing an angular training
okay so alpha is in a triangle of
writing in front of it with these ratios
or sides okay so if I draw out don't
worry about scale put alpha here you
know writing with right cause is
batricia adjacent right so this is your
adjacent and this is your hypotenuse
okay so here's eleven and here's 12 now
what does that tell you the other side
is use Pythagoras
yeah you get 144 121 yeah
okay so therefore I can say if that's
what cos alpha is sine alpha should be
opposite hypotenuse right 23 as well now
before you leave off right you have to
be careful you get a value but you know
when you got restrictions on that man
you always need to be careful okay
so you look at this and then you check
it now between 0 and 180 which quadrants
is that it's one into Austin is to
concentrate was it every day to me like
I say in Curtis wanted to sign as in
sign assignee is positive okay so so far
so good
okay you come over here and beta is in a
completely different triangle okay so
what your drawer is okay now by the way
I what I'm doing is I'm making the
answer that's in the solution you guys
know if you remember I showed you how to
draw this with negatives in it because
you're in another quadrant but this
approach is fine okay Joey is a regular
triangle everything positive and then
you come back to the domain is okay
right right so sine is opposite over
hypotenuse you have two on three which
gives you the other side being rude five
okay so cos beta adjacent and hypotenuse
okay now again you look at your domain
which is ninety two seventy which is
which quadrants
two and three okay two and three both of
them cosine is negative right so I need
to slap a minus sign on the front there
it makes it beware don't make me go all
right that's a hot pot I've done Albert
tricky bits I just have to take one two
three four bits and just combine them in
this way so I would say sine alpha minus
UV is okay sine alpha cos beta minus the
other ones cos alpha you guys take it
from there is that enough I think you
guys are capable
yeah okay what now so what you need to
think about is okay so then let's pick
one shall we if they told you sorry
you mean if sine alpha was 11 or 12
yeah that's right see what they're doing
massive as a teacher sending a question
either you careful write that ever
contradict myself I should give you
these two together will be enough
information to conclusively
unambiguously work out the sine of okay
cuz it can't be both at the same time if
you want to size it up well you said you
were still no what do you mean
it could have been because if it was
different then it would be the one that
you know about already they would tell
you and so you know what yeah that's
right that's why it will exist so you
can see in Siberia if it was most two or
three okay and it's between 90 and 270
so you know how you're down here you see
that because I can't be up here
because sign is there so in fact it's
actually giving you a little more
information
I hate telling you this okay cause it
copy